i have a question i watch the walking
dead and i have questions
no zombie animals no zombie animals
there must be zombies that bite an
animal every now and then and
and why aren't there you know little
baby chicks walking around
you know why aren't there snakes going
slither slither
uh the the honest answer to that is uh
walking dead is based on a comic book
the artist that draws the comic book
charlie adlard
uh loves drawing people loves drawing
zombies does not enjoy drawing animals
so much
also so when we sit down we look at the
comic and we're like oh we got to turn
this into a show
they go hey there's no uh no zombie
animals in there uh okay we're not gonna
put that in the show
right okay my next question is about the
speed of zombies
um some zombies walk incredibly slowly
they're just so
slow and when i'm watching i think i'm
not scared of that zombie
i could get away i got plenty of time to
get away from that zombie
other zombies seem a little more agile
are these zombies that work out
are they zombies that do they carbo load
early in the day
why are some zombies apparently faster
than others uh you know they like to uh
they like to change it up they like to
keep you guessing you know they get the
slow zombies out there sometimes they
bring in the uh fast zombies to surprise
you right people like you are like oh
zombies nothing to worry about and then
all of a sudden there's a fast one
there's a fast one and it freaks me out
when there's a fast zombie i like to
think it has something to do with how
fresh they are you know like a fresh
zombie can move a little faster because
he's a little fresher of a
dead body i mean they're all dead bodies
right yeah uh so uh
i think about this so a fresher zombie
like a zombie that's only been dead for
a while
moves quickly and then uh smells better
and smell yeah unless he's got the
perfume and then there's a
then there's an older zombie that's been
around for a while and maybe one of its
legs fell off and that zombie you don't
have to worry about as much his muscles
are decaying he's not moving so fast
right okay this is fantastic i find this
fascinating because
the other thing i want to ask you about
and andy i know that you watch the show
as well
and this is something that i had a
question about which is i get so mad at
the group's decisions
sometimes sometimes they make the
dumbest decisions and i'm screaming at
the screen
someone will go someone will lose their
shoe and they'll say where is it
it's in that cornfield filled with
zombies
what do we do and someone will say i got
it let's
break up into nine groups run in there
in the dark and meet back in six
months okay that's not an exact
plot yeah i'm gonna
but that's how it he was only going to
use that now
yeah i'm going to write that down yeah
but it was only three months they were
going to come out of the cornfield in
three months
they're always subdividing and running
off into the night and i'm like everyone
stay together
it's so that the zombies can pick them
off individually yes
thank you this is why i'm not this is
why i'm not writing for the walking dead
i'd have them all hiding out in a mall
eating
really like cinnabon and with with the
doors chained nobody gets hurt and
everybody eats cinnabon for months
that would be my walking dead that
sounds okay to me you want to come in
and guess write an episode i want to be
in an episode
that's my next question no celebrity
cameos now in this world
a conan o'brien could exist why couldn't
there be a dead zombie
conan o'brien talk show host who
shuffles through
i can see there's not a lot of popular
support for this idea
oh no no no no no no
no no no no no too late
uh if you think about it realistically
all the celebrities would have gotten
eaten first
you think so i mean if you're a zombie
like uh what are you gonna eat you're
gonna eat some normal person you're
gonna need a celebrity you'd be like i
recognize him
they probably they probably taste better
they're usually leaner you know i
that's true i'm just thinking about it
logically um
again uh you've answered every question
that i've had i want to point one thing
out right
you're very good a little too good
but i want to make you aware of
something uh the theme
music for the walking dead is so scary
every time i watch the show it
immediately from the second it begins
puts me in the mood
to see zombies and puts me in that world
and we just try and experiment and
we couldn't believe how well it synced
up but we put the walking dead
theme music on the opening of our show
to show you
how good this music is and how much it
actually alters your perception of what
you're about to see
take a look at our show with walking
dead music
i'm scared of everything the car
i'm frightened of james franco now
i'd watch that show yeah i'd watch that
show